Star Wars: The Last Jedi somehow managed to
keep pre-release details shrouded in secrecy
- and that caused fans to dream up their own
unusual theories and speculations before even
buying a ticket.
Considering that at two and a half hours,
The Last Jedi is the longest franchise entry
to-date, there's a lot to look forward to
that no amount of teasers could possibly spoil.
But some of the behind-the-scenes details
surrounding the movie were guarded a little
less under carefully.
From Easter egg reveals to production conflicts
as well as even one or two plot-related scoops
that came through a little earlier than expected,
here's what you might not know about Episode
8.
One last stand
Due to the unexpected passing of actress Carrie
Fisher, Princess Leia's planned appearance
in Episode 9 became a point of major speculation
for fans.
Given that her part in the next film was supposed
to be enhanced, the loss made some fans wonder
whether the filmmakers might digitally insert
her into Episode 9 like they had in Rogue
One.
Lucasfilm boss Kathleen Kennedy, however,
dispelled rumors of a potential CGI Leia appearance
in Episode 9 and said The Last Jedi will mark
Princess Leia's last physical appearance in
the Star Wars universe.
Perhaps it's a fitting final stand for Fisher
because, as director Rian Johnson has since
revealed, she was instrumental in his script-writing
process for the picture.
Johnson said that while developing Episode
8, he'd go to her house and talk with her
about the script; what resulted were "...a
kind of stream of consciousness, jazz poetry
sessions" and that their conversations usually
led to changes in the script, such as in the
dialogue.
Considering a large portion of Fisher's non-Star
Wars career was spent doctoring screenplays
like this, The Last Jedi sounds like it'll
feature a culmination of her many talents.
Actor objections
It's no secret that Mark Hamill hasn't been
entirely pleased with the process of bringing
Star Wars back for the New Trilogy.
First, he was disappointed over his lack of
screentime in The Force Awakens and its treatment
of Han Solo, and now, he's taken umbrage with
Rian Johnson's vision for The Last Jedi.
In an interview with Vanity Fair, Hamill said
that he confronted Johnson about his thoughts
on the script, and told him,
"I pretty much fundamentally disagree with
every choice you've made for this character."
Luckily for Johnson, though, Hamill wasn't
put off enough to walk away and instead, he
told the writer-director,
"Having said that, I have gotten it off my
chest, and my job now is to take what you've
created and do my best to realize your vision."
So even though The Last Jedi will feature
a Luke Skywalker that Luke Skywalker himself
doesn't approve of, at least the actor will
be giving it his best effort.
Unique influences
Even if Mark Hamill doesn't quite get his
vision, Rian Johnson sure boasts some novel
sources of inspiration for his segment of
the Star Wars films.
For example, the aerial dogfights and space
combat seen in The Last Jedi were at least
partially inspired by 1949's Twelve O'Clock
High, an American war drama about the U.S.
Air Force's involvement in World War II.
Additionally, 1964's Three Outlaw Samurai
has impacted his directing style, meaning
that that movie's pulpy plot and hack-'n-slash
sword fighting action will have a presence
among the space drama and fancy lightsabers
of Star Wars.
The film series drawing influence from classic
films is nothing new, since A New Hope borrowed
from 1954's The Dam Busters and Akira Kurosawa's
1958 film The Hidden Fortress, so while those
might not be the most ordinary muse movies,
maybe this means an even truer return to classic
Star Wars.
Royal cameo
If you were tickled by the news that James
Bond actor Daniel Craig had a cameo in The
Force Awakens, well, you're in for a royal
surprise in The Last Jedi.
"There's loads of rumors man, but you know
it's a hard secret to keep, you know the Royal
Family in the, in the Star Wars universe?
I'm sure you wouldn't be able to keep that
secret."
"I know nothing"
Princes Harry and William were both seen on-set
goofing around, and actor John Boyega confirmed
that Tom Hardy was there as well.
Boyega said of the surprise guests,
"They were there.
I'm sick of hiding it.
I think it was leaked, anyway.
There were images."
He took it a step further in November, 2017
by telling The Hollywood Reporter that not
only would both princes appear as stormtroopers
in the film — in addition to Hardy and singer
Gary Barlow— but they'd all donned the instantly
recognizable armor for the same scene.
Scar switcheroo
When it came to Kylo Ren's gnarly facial scar,
Rian Johnson has admitted that he moved it
simply because it didn't look right back in
The Force Awakens.
Now it resides on Kylo's right cheek rather
than the bridge of his nose… not because
of midichlorians, but just because of his
own personal preference.
It's not exactly universe-shattering canon
reconfiguration there, but it is something
Kylo Ren's fans will certainly take notice
of.
Code name
Just as Return of the Jedi used the fake working
title "Blue Harvest" to fool autograph-seeking
fans during filming, The Last Jedi had its
own pretend moniker in play while the cameras
were still rolling on the film.
But instead of holding any clues to the substance
of Episode 8, the fake name was simply "Space
Bear."
Yep, Space Bear.
That might be some subtle nod to Chewbacca
or one of the other furry creatures coming
along in The Last Jedi, or the fact that porgs
are basically the new Ewoks … or it might
just be Rian Johnson toying with everyone
because he can.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!